Марусяк Любов Миколаївна і та повезло що
фамілію не міняло бо і тато Марусяк
Микола Миколайович і чоловік прийшов
сюда Марусяк Микола
Миколайович займалися така радиці з діда
прадіда чолові робо починається ранку з
того що треба подоїти корови і вівці бо
цей бус який ми робимо то є суміш
овечого і коровичого молока тоді ми вже
до нього додаємо такий фермент яко
називається глек який робить жолудочка
теляти ви так ще мусить підсушитися
стоєть -4ри дні і Аж тоді ми його
кладемо коптити і тоді вже цей такий має
вигляд такий
буц І коли вже він підсушиться тоді вже
його подрібнюємо додаємо силі вже такий
кінцевий результат
бренза
96 років ні одного дня хата не пустувала
постійно але склад як Брин заробити - це
таємни
ну суміш овеч і короючого молока в одну
посудинку завдяки тому що ви підписали
угоду про асоціацію в Україну зайшов
такий проект підтримка географічних
зазначень в Україні і завдяки тому що
Європейський союз фінансував цей проект
в нас у Верховині створилася громадська
спілка асоціація Карпатських ватагів ми
мали національних експертів і
міжнародних експертів які приїжджали до
нас і допомагали у реєстрації
географічного зазна че гуцульська
коровіч принц
Дуже дякую вам спасибі Вам м дякую
спасибі Наступного разу ще раз приїдемо
в гості дуже смачна бринза і дуже
смачний
[музика]
ба
і не жалію ні одного дня що я залишилася
тут я не
жалію на морі не була хотілося бути
жартують Я б на море А
корова Якщо хочеш в тої метушнії трошки
такої самотохи десь піднятися і
пороздумати собі налаштуватися на далі
як жити то то є плюс у такому що дійсно
дальше і і вище
[музика]